all the talk about dangerous winter
weather may get you thinking about a
2018 getaway travel website kayak this
morning is launching its annual travel
hacker guide a team of data scientists
and experts analyzed the sites more than
one-and-a-half billion annual searches
to determine where to go and when to
book their findings showed January is
the least expensive month to travel
within the US for international trips
try March and the cheapest days to fly
domestically are typically Tuesdays and
Saturdays Dave Salim Ito is kayaks vice
president of marking marketing welcome
thank you okay so let's start with these
top trending destinations or places
where you saw a big uptick in searches
Maui Hawaii number one absolutely
Nellie's always popular it's kind of a
quintessential Hawaiian experience you
have luxury but you also have some of
the local culture that's there and in
response airlines have added routes so
it's become more accessible and it's
become more affordable so we saw over
51% increase in searches to Maui on
kayak it also probably doesn't hurt that
Gail's there right now outside Hawaii
seems like a really good idea five of
the seven out of the top 10 trending
destinations are in Europe yeah it's a
perennial favorite it really surprised
how knowing how popular Europe is
generally to see those destinations
trending meaning they're seeing more
searches this year than last year the
big thing driving that is the low-cost
carriers really driving down prices with
competition so last summer we saw
flights to Europe 20 to 30 percent
cheaper than the summer before and for
the summer of 2018 we expect them to be
even lower so if you were thinking about
exploring Barcelona if you were thinking
about checking out the food scene in
Rome this could be the time to do it
this year how far in advance should we
be booking it's a question we get often
people want to know is there a secret
formula I think the the looking at the
guide for the United States and the
Caribbean about a month before your trip
is a sweet spot really and then on the
other end of the spectrum if you're
traveling to Europe or Africa six months
in advance is the best time to book for
the cheapest flights for the cheapest
flights and kayak also offers a price
forecast tool so for your particular
search it recommends whether you should
book your flight now or wait but those
are
general guidelines we give people
heading in to make a make a search
what's the best bargain spot for people
who just have an open map in front of
them for sure I think looking at the
guide we had a we curated wallet for any
lists based on the the kayak data and
Americans looking for a bargain spot
should think about going north or south
of the border the number-one bargain
destination was in Guadalajara Mexico
it's pretty affordable and there's also
a tequila train which you can take and
the country it's becoming a thing like
sort of like wine tasting you do tequila
tasting so it's pretty fun and then the
number two budget destination was in
Calgary so it's a affordable city
affordable flights and then once you're
there you're not too far from the
Canadian Rockies and Banff which is one
of the most Instagram level places in
the entire world it's absolutely
gorgeous
Calgary is great you can do the rodeo
yeah tequila train all aboard all of it
thanks very much thank you you got it